please dear brothers move forward and
please
if you come
in the another juma
direct sit down
in the front of
the head
jazakum allah
and also we have the two rooms
here in cornell you can go to to there
just
dear brothers
and sisters
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
in the quran
there is nothing that you have except
that it is
a blessing from allah
allah also subhanahu wa allah says
in the quran
if you try to count the bounties of
allah
you would not
be able
muslims
know that among allah's blessings
is that he gave you
the gift of islam
allah has blessed you with this
while he has made it a trial
for some others
because
he wants
to separate
those who are good
from those who are evil
allah
says in the quran
owns everything
that is
in the heavens and the earth
he creates
what
he wills
and he grant
some people
female child children while he grant
other male children
after
the blessing of islam
one of the
greatest
blessings that allah granted the human
beings in a child
is a child
especially righteous children
no one knows
the true blessings of having a child
except those who are
deprived
of this
there have been many people who have not
been able to became
mothers or fathers
you see them striving day
and night to have a child
we must remember
though
that the power of allah is above the
ability of any doctor or worldly
procedures
he tests
his creation
and
he also
blesses his creation
so his creation should then be patient
and call on another to patients
and they should enjoy
good amongst one another
so that they may be successful
and children
are the declaration of worldly life
so
children are a pleasure for us in this
life
the prophet
be muhammed him said
truly
your children have right over you
so
we must
be careful about
how we raise our children
we may we must treat them with love
respect
and kindness
and should not
oppress them
if children are raised in their wrong
way
we cannot
expect them to be yours
applied
and
we must always remember that
allah
is watching us
there are
some parents
who could not raise their children
properly
they neglected them
and their children
became
disrespectful
and maybe even were laid to trade
this is
an issue
that we see in our everyday lives
these youth
have reached the age of young
adulthood
but
their behavior
is still
childish
they do more bad things
than goods
may allah grant him mercy said
whoever
neglects
raising a
needle teaching
and raising his children correctly has
certainly
certainly done his children
disservice
when parents neglect
to teach
the obligations of islam
and
the traditions of the messengers
children
became lost
they do not benefit in themselves nor
their parents
we need
to ask
how can a father
and
a mother
be at peace while their children are
outside the house
doing all kinds of bad things
it is
is this
the proper way
to raise children
don't the parents need to learn
proper behavior towards their children
the answer
is yes
if the parents
not the prayer
those children
follow who
maybe
we'll follow
that
people in the school and the university
allah says
in the quran
and who is more in just and just than
one who is reminded of verses of his
lord but turns away
from them
and forgets
what his hands
have put forth
indeed
we have played over their hearts
governance
then they understand it
and in there
is deafness
and if you invite them
to guidance
they will never be guided
then ever
so
it is
it instantly clear that children must be
taking care of their youth
they must be
raised in a proper manner so that they
can become righteous members of their
communities and
society
so
fear allah
when it comes to your children
take care
in doing what allah commanded you
by raising them in a proper manner
and remember
the day of judgment
that we will
all have to face
allah says
in the quran
stop them
because
they will be questioned
dear brothers
and sisters
i call
on you to bring your children
to masjid
so that their hearts become attached
to it
you must have them
participate in the programs that we have
set up for them
so
so that they can be
true colors to islam
they will learn to understand
their religion
and
become men and women of piety
they will be able to serve
the religion of allah just the
children of their companions may allah
be pleased with them
this
will be source
of ongoing charity
for
upon him said
if a human being dies
all actions
all actions are cut off
except three
an ongoing chargeable deed
knowledge that benefited others
or
arachio's child
who pray who prays
for the
deceased
or our lord
give us righteous
spouses
and
righteous
of supreme
that will be a pleasure for our eyes
i seek i seek allah's forgiveness for
myself
for you
our children
for our parents
and all the muslims
of islam
happiness
[Silence]
is